the new Claude 3.5 Sonic from anthropic
their Flagship language model is a
significant step forward wait no not
particularly because it can use a mouse
to perform a basic Google search I'll
dive into a couple of papers to show
that not all is as it seems on that
front and for now I can browse Google
for National Park photos myself no for
me the new 3.5 Sonic is a step forward
because yet again we have progress on
that nebulous front we call reasoning
and I do have some new evidence to back
that up plus time waits for no man and
so while anthropic were cooking Heen and
Runway were also in the kitchen stirring
up AI you can zoom chat with and create
movie scenes alongside most of this
stuff of course has only been out a day
or at most two but here are my first
impressions and the first tldr I'll give
is don't sleep on the new claw 3.5 Sonic
even if you're not interested in an llm
taking over your computer it's reasoning
coding and visual processing abilities
are a step forward I'll also touch on
one of its key weaknesses in just a few
minutes first of course the name and
somewhat confusingly it's still 3.5
Sonic just with brackets new feels like
they could have called it at least 3.6
Sonic but for now that new is the
giveaway you're using a new model it has
knowledge of world events up until April
of 2024 which is not bad compared to 01
previews October 2023 naturally though
most of the attention will be focused on
the new claw 3.5 Sonet ability to use
your computer via an API I think it's
safe to say that as of today that won't
see broad public adoption because of its
unreliability and the long list of
things that it can't do like send emails
make purchases technically complete
captures or edit or manipulate images I
feel like it's more anthropic dipping
their toe into the water and it looks
like it's found
something great so how far away is the
location from my place it's opening
maps searching for the distance between
my area and the hiking location
[Music]
cool so now it looks like clot is
searching for the sunrise time
tomorrow and is now dropping it into my
calendar but from what we know so far
how does the new claw 3.5 Sonic actually
do when given tasks the first Benchmark
that anthropic cites in the paper is the
OS World Benchmark naturally I read that
paper to get some more context on what
the 3.5 model can actually do and I was
impressed it's over 350 tasks covering
professional use Office use and daily
use like shopping one small detail from
this paper that I think many analysts
might miss is how they derived the human
average not only were these tasks like
changing the settings in a set of slides
in a presentation new to both the humans
and the models look at which humans they
used these were computer science Majors
college students who possess basic
software usage skills but have not been
exposed to these exact samples or the
software before so when you hear about
human performance accuracy on this
Benchmark being around 72% that's a
fairly High bar of human performance or
going back to the Sonic paper they're
not comparing Claude 3.5 Sonic to a
bunch of old bitties these are comp
science Majors anyway if given 50 steps
Claude 3.5 Sonet the new one gets 22%
versus these compai Majors getting 72%
now I can see someone at the back
raising their hand saying well the
Benchmark States it has to be done in 15
Steps and that's where Claude 3.5 Sonic
new gets 15% what if the humans were
given 50 steps which is where Claude
gets 22% but still my only point is that
if you were to compare Claude 3.5
Sonic's performance to literally an
average human someone not particularly
vers in computers I think the Delta
would be much smaller and in software
engineering Claude 3.5 Sonic would
absolutely Crush that old biddy no but
to be slightly more serious in The
Benchmark the open AI itself created swe
bench software engineering bench
verified Claude 3.5 Sonic the new one
I'm going to have to keep saying new
gets 49% and that beats 01 preview I dug
into the 01 paper to get this comparison
where you can see even pre mitigation 01
preview gets
38.4% in this software engineering
Benchmark compared to post mitigation
after safety training getting 28% now of
course it's hard to have an Apples to
Apples comparison because it depends on
prompting and Scaffolding but you can
see as of today the new 3.5 Sonic is the
best in that Benchmark as you might
expect I'm not just going to rely on
published Benchmark performance though I
ran my own Benchmark simple bench on the
new 3.5 Sonic and I'm going to give you
the results in a moment in this chart
though you can see the comparison
between the new claw 3.5 Sonet and the
original claw 3.5 Sonet as well as
interestingly GPT 40 but not 01 preview
so what most people want to know is is
it better is it smarter and the answer
there is a resounding yes if you're
asking it a challenging Science question
it will do better than the previous
Claude 3.5 Sonet in general knowledge
again it knows more in coding as we've
seen it's simply better than the
original 3.5 Sonet likewise in
mathematics it's a step up and even in
visual question answering answering
questions from tables charts and graphs
it's slightly better than the previous
version and you're about to see see
further results confirming how much of a
step forward it is so many
congratulations to anthropic and so for
the vast majority of people those are
the headlines but for the llm Nerds like
me and some of you watching we probably
would have liked to see a direct
comparison with 01 preview and that does
seem to be an industry Trend where for
these Benchmark figures companies pick
the comparisons they want to make which
rival models they include and which they
don't here's just another quick example
with the release of the mini straw
models 3B and 8B from Mistral that's the
small French outfit that is holding the
torch for Mainland Europe in AI anyway
in the small model category here are the
sets of results that they released this
was just a Week Ago by the way and all
seems fine and good until the principal
researcher at Google deep mine pointed
out that they missed out Gemma 29b from
Deep mind adding that Row in makes the
results look slightly different I'm not
trying to make this a major points I'm
going to move on in just a moment but
just to give you an idea let's take GP
QA where the new Sonic gets 65% 01
preview gets 78.3 and the full 01
interestingly slightly down 78.0 on the
M mmu which I think is a really great
Benchmark again testing whether you can
read from graphs tables charts and the
like we have Claude 3.5 Sonic getting
70.4 and the new 01 which admittedly
isn't out yet getting
78.2 you can see here finally in a
particularly famous high school math
competition we have the new Sonic
getting 16% 01 preview getting
56.7% and 01 getting 83% let me put it
this way I think the new Sonic is going
to be massively underestimated I think
it's actually really good at reasoning
maybe not these super calculation heavy
computation heavy things like 01 can do
just general basic reasoning and
creative writing as you might expect
I've already tested it hundreds of times
and I can attest to that fact I just
wanted to make the simple point that
sometimes the model providers choose the
comparisons they want to showcase on
that point anthropics say this our
evaluation tables exclude open AI 01
model family as they depend on extensive
pre-response computation time unlike the
typical models this fundamental
difference in operation makes
performance comparisons difficult and
outside the scope of this report well
one of the leaders on the work on 01
Jerry twark said this being hard to
compare against because of fundamental
differences is the highest form of
flattery but here's a new one what about
the Intriguing towel bench at the bottom
hm that's new retail Airline well of
course I dug into that paper and noticed
that one of the authors is my friend
Noah Shin so that's cool the short
version is that it's a benchmark that
tests if an AI agent can do shopping for
you or book an airline ticket but it has
some really interesting nuggets they
have a pass to the power of K not pass
at k pass to the power of K so what's
the difference there if you hear
something like pass at 8 that means does
a model get it right once in eight
attempts if you hear pass to the power
of K which I think is a brilliant device
that's did it pass all eight times for
agent tasks of course that's crucial
it's no good getting it right once out
of eight then you'll be flying to bloody
Mongolia it has to be right every single
time oh and by the way the company
behind this Benchmark is now valued at
over 4 billion just casually I believe
they're trying to automate customer
service and that reminds me with these
valuations it's a bit like they might
only have a 3% chance or a 4% chance of
automating customer service but if they
do and they get the financial rewards
for doing so then they're going to be
worth like a trillion so for me when I
hear a $4 billion valuation I don't
think they're literally worth 4 billion
I think just my opinion of of course I
think it's like 90% chance they're worth
very little or a small amount but then a
10% chance or 4% chance they're worth
trillions anyway the tasks are kind of
as you'd expect it'll be helping users
cancel or modify pending orders
returning delivered orders modifying
user addresses that kind of thing for
the retail Benchmark and then for the to
Airline part of the Benchmark which of
course is much higher Stakes the agent
has to help users book modify or cancel
flight reservations and here are the
headline results and this is what I
meant in the introduction when I said
not all is as it seems for these set of
results I really think is worth paying
attention because the next 6 months 18
months could be dominated by AI agents
and the related benchmarks do you get it
right in one try yes Claude 3.5 Sonic
the new one is significantly better than
the previous version I admire anthropic
for putting out these results because
they don't always shine the best light
on the new Sonic at least I'm talking
for computer use again reasoning amazing
because for the airline tasks 46% given
one try isn't amazing and here is the
most important chart I think it sums up
maybe the next 6 to 18 months what about
pass to the power of K where K is say 8
I just want to restate what that means
for extra Clarity to pass to the power
of eight you have to get it right and
then right and then right eight times
times one mistake once on your seventh
try screws up the entire trial and so
what we get for Sonic and I suspect all
language models including 01 is a
reverse scaling law as you scale up the
number of attempts performance
consistently drops this I suspect is the
kind of scaling that currently AI CEOs
don't really want you to focus on this
was for the slightly easier retail task
and if you just ask it once look we get
70% for the new on it but then eight
times what is that about 40% and it's
still going down of course imagine this
was 100 tries or 100 customers I'm just
saying this reminds me that reliability
is the single barrier left I feel to
massive economic impact from AI talking
specifically about llms here they can
quote achieve harder and harder tasks
like getting 80% in the GP QA but that
won't mean that much until the
reliability on basic tasks gets better
mind you I don't think that's terribly
far away especially when we scale up
test time computes but that's a story
for another day another quick one
interestingly the new Sonic is actually
slightly worse at refusals in other
words it correctly refuses wild chat
toxic requests slightly less often it
incorrectly refuses innocent requests
slightly more often than the previous
model not super dramatically I just
thought that was interesting to note do
you remember from the 01 release how it
actually performed slightly worse in
creative writing compared to GPT 40 well
that's not the case for the new 3.5
Sonet it crushes 58% of the time at
least the original Claude 3.5 Sonet
interestingly on multilingual challenges
it's slightly worse than the previous
version of 3.5 Sonic but what about my
own Benchmark simple bench well I Tred
to get crazy ambitious with majority
voting and architectures involving
self-consistency but in the end that
just slightly delayed me so I just want
to get it out to you as soon as possible
myself and the senior Mo engineer that
I'm working with on simple bench did
agree that we should probably put out a
technical memo paper or report something
to indicate our thinking on that matter
and that report has taken slightly
longer than I expected which is why I
can't just as of today release this
website but I can release the
provisional leaderboard Syle bench is a
test that can be taken by
non-specialized humans from any
background as long as they can speak
English it ask questions about how
things move in space and time and also
test social intelligence we ran the new
Claude 3.5 Sonic this morning and saw a
significant step up from the previous
version notice also we have the latest
results from the new Gemini 1.5 Pro and
where is it the command r+ that's the
new one grock 2 the API became available
fairly recently and for those of you who
have been following the channel for a
while you might have noticed that the
human Baseline has dropped a bit that's
because we expanded the scope out to
nine people this time the human top
performance is still around 96% I think
it's
95.7% we expanded the scope and dropped
the requirement to be a graduate this
was nine human beings from truly
eclectic backgrounds the only
commonality is that they spoke English
natively that's the average we got
83.7% the average of five means we ran
for the models The Benchmark five times
in in full and average the results you
might remember what I was saying about
self-consistency I don't want to get
into it here but that's not the same as
just averaging the results it was very
complicated and it actually hurt model
performance that's a story for another
day but I wanted models to shine as much
as they could and some of you may be
wondering at this point if I followed
the recent debates in the last couple of
weeks about models reasoning and whether
prompting can overcome those limitations
yes it can boost performance including
to slightly above 50% but we're still
nowhere near to human Baseline and
that's with an optimized prompt I will
say to some of you who are new to the
channel That through prompting and a
particular scaffolding myself and Josh
an ml engineer came up with Smart gbt in
May of last year which got at the time a
record
89.0% on the mlu so yes I know that
prompting can help but simple bench is a
pretty resilient Benchmark these
questions were of course vetted multiple
times exhaustively including by Dr level
researchers and they weren't like the
somewhat flippant example I gave a
couple of videos ago about a table being
tilted I kind of meant that one as a
quick illustration but obviously that
backfired so apologies for the confusion
I should probably scroll down because we
did also do GPT 4 mini and you can see
the performance so yes in short even in
my own Benchmark I can confirm that the
new Sonic is a marked improvement I'm
not the only one who has been impressed
of course and earlier in the video I
showed you the reasons not to be over
hyped but there are some reasons to be
just a little bit excited or terrified
depending on your perspective and I
can't resist telling you that simple
bench will be sponsored by weights and
biases and that isn't a random
sponsorship I am incredibly selective in
who I work with on sponsorships and yes
they are sponsoring this video and we
use weave for simple bench that's how we
could do an incredibly quick turnaround
on the new Sonic results my own custom
link should be showing on screen and
will of course be in the description but
don't forget they also have free courses
in their AI Academy now I can't resist
taking a 10-second interlude to point
out something you may have heard about
already which is that Claude at one
point took a break during a coding demo
to peruse photos of the Yellowstone
National Park whether that's
misalignment or massively amusing will
of course depend on your perspective but
it must be said that Claude isn't the
only thing that was dropped yesterday
here's act one from from Runway ml while
this particular development and the
other two I'm about to show you might
not completely blow off your socks they
do point to the unrelenting Improvement
in AI generated entertainment that's
coming with runways act one you can see
the actress driving the performance
showing emotion and creativity in their
performance and then that being
generated by the model into different
character animations in all sorts of
styles the lip syncing isn't quite there
yet but nevertheless here is a 15-second
scene you really think you can just walk
away from all
this I have
to there's no other choice there's
always a choice you just don't like the
Alternatives what would you me do stay
just watch it all crumble around me
that's what you signed up for you can
let me know what you think in the
comments but while Generations have this
AI tinge about them I wonder if they
will struggle to achieve public
acceptance I suspect the impact of this
kind of technology in video games will
be much greater than in movies and TV
where people want everything to be
perfect then there's hen's new
interactive Avatar and I think this one
somewhat flew under the radar I will
admit that the lip syncing again is not
the best but did you know you can have a
zoom call with one of these avatars like
literally you open the tab and it's a
zoom meeting you log in and then
chatting to this AI model right at the
beginning of this year I predicted that
this would happen this year but I didn't
think it would come from someone like
hey Jen I thought he might come from
open AI but either way true Zoom calls
with AI models is now a reality hey
Vicki this is Phillip from AI explained
and I'm actually testing you for a video
that's going to go out on YouTube and
can you confirm this is a live Zoom call
I see Philip just to clarify this is a
simulated roleplay for conversation
practice not a live Zoom call however
I'm here to help you navigate any
scenarios you want to explore what
specific conversation would you like to
roleplay well it's kind of live I mean
you're not alive but it's live in the
sense of I'm speaking to you now and
you're reacting in real time
right got it Philip you're right I'm
reacting in real time so let's focus on
your video content What scenario do you
want a role play that relates to your
project I'm just going to demonstrate
how I can interrupt you although you
just stopped speaking immediately but
yeah your lip syncing is very good but
it's slightly stilted I can tell you're
not real it's not super easy but I can
tell I understand philli I'm here to
support your demonstration if you'd like
we can roleplay a scenario where you
provide okay I'm going to interrupt you
nowly but can you just give a message to
my viewers
sure thing Phillip just let me know what
message you'd like me to convey to your
viewers no when you are no I want you
that was weird I want you to come up
with a message for my YouTube
subscribers got it here's a message hey
everyone Thanks for tuning in if you're
enjoying the content don't forget to
like subscribe and hit that notification
Bell yeah your support means the world
Stak yeah guys do it great message thank
you Vicki I didn't catch can you still
see me so I think you get the idea now
but the final of the three updates on
different modalities comes from of
course notebook LM using Gemini 1.5 Pro
they can analyze a source that you feed
it for free and generate through text to
speech and engaging podcast now you guys
already knew that cuz I've covered that
before on this channel but here's
something you might not know after you
choose a file to upload then after 30
seconds or so you will see a new button
customize not just generate and I think
this is really cool if you haven't
already seen it but you click customize
and then you can focus the podcast
conversation pick one topic out of a
video you feed in or a PDF focus on this
and not on that explain it in a way
that's good for this audience or that
audience basically customization of a
tool that was already pretty cool maybe
half of you might already know about
that capability but for the other half
do check out notebook LM of course the
news for me Remains the release of the
new 3.5 Sonic and those were my
takeaways from all the associated papers
the timing was great because I've just
recovered from what could be either
covid or heavy cold but I am back in
action and really looking forward to
fully releasing simple bench of course
would love to see you over on insiders
and quite topically from anthropic
here's my 35 minute analysis of their
CEO's Deep dive on a compressed 21st
century do check it out but regardless
thank you so much for watching and have
a wonderful day